[Music]
we were able to work on this project
with multiple government stakeholders to
come up with a new prototype
to bring the kung pong spirit which
celebrates healthy communal living
into the urban setting of singapore the
overarching theme of this project is
connection
and integration it is a new prototype of
mixed use which combines public housing
for the elderly
republic space and park medical health
and recreational amenities
retail shops food centre and an urban
farm
the first challenge we faced was how to
accommodate all the facilities on this
very small site
our design approach is to layer these
different programs vertically
so there are three layers the lowest
layer is the ground layer with
supermarket retail shops and food center
and by
compacting this commercial footprint we
freed the ground floor
for a tropical plaza and by lifting the
medical center to the middle layer
we can have all the weather activities
in a fully public
porous and pedestrianized plaza below
the upper level
is for community users of a quieter
nature
such as the child care elder care and
elderly housing apartments
over all these uses we created a new
elevated ground level by introducing
a community sky garden where young and
all can come together
so instead of standalone programs we
have created
a layered more integrated urban village
with all these mixed uses
and its tropical community spaces
our approach in kampung mrot is
three-dimensional programming
multiplying and maximizing the building
systems of greenery and community spaces
making both systems useful and enjoyable
the integrated design of compound
emerity and the extensive programming by
all the various stakeholders have
actually helped to encourage
our senior residents to get out of their
flats
socialize with their neighbours and
pursue their interests
you